ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY DODD
OSEM EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO OTTO
JONES LAYERED LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN
I'LL SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG MY CASKEY WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING YOU BE LET IN
THE PLEDGE BY SENATOR. WHITE
HOUSE YOU. MEMBERS IF YOU COULD
JOIN ME IN PRAYER THIS MORNING.
SOLEMN SPIRITS AS WE COMBAT THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE'VE LOST OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS
TO THIS TRAGEDY PLEASE JOIN ME
IN PRAYING FOR THEIR FAMILIES
THEIR LEGACIES IN WHAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN HAD WE GOTTEN AHEAD
NATIONALLY OF THIS TRAGEDY. WE
HAVE GREAT OPTIMISM AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. HAS MORE MORE VACCINES
BECOME AVAILABLE AND MORE MORE
CALIFORNIA'S GET VACCINATED AND
PRACTICE GOOD SOUND SOCIAL
DISTANCING WE PRAY FOR THAT
EFFORT WE PRAY. FOR THOSE WHO
WORK IN THE CAPITAL WHO HAVE
BEEN BRAVE AND ALL OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE IN MEDICAL
CARE WHO HAVE REACHED. THEIR
OWN SITUATION TO HELP THOSE
LESS FORTUNATE PLEASE JOIN ME
IN PRAYER A MAN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS SHOULD
DAY WILL HAVE SOONER LIMóN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SO GOOD
MORNING SENATOR LIMóN
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR AS-
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION. WILL
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEM NUMBER TNF A. B.
EIGHTY SIX SENATOR SKINNER YOU
PREPARED FOR. AB EIGHTY SIX
FILE ITEM TEN MCGUIRE. NO. ONE
MOMENT A PRESIDING OFFICER
ROBERT. THANK YOU. MATHIS
SURGERY BLEACH FRIEDMAN HAD
OCCURRED. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SKINNER SKINNER
FOURS ARE YOURS THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MEMBERS BY. VERY HONORED
TO PRESENT TO YOU AB EIGHTY SIX
WHICH IS AN EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A IN AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO PROVIDE A PATH TO
RETURN TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AT OUR SCHOOLS AND TO GET OUR
CHILDREN BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM. IT EMPHASIZES THE
SAFETY FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF.
WHICH MEANS THEN IT'S RICH IT'S
RECOGNIZING OR EMPHASIZING THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES SINCE
OUR CHILDREN AND STAFF. MOVE IN
AND OUT OF THOSE COMMUNITIES IF
THEY'RE GOING TO SCHOOL AND WE
KNOW THAT STOPPING THE SPREAD
OF THIS VIRUS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO RIGHT
NOW. SO IT EMPHASIZES THAT
SAFETY AND IT RESPECTS THE
DIFFERING LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES
ACROSS THE STATE PROVIDING KEY
FLEXIBILITY TO HELP OUR
CLASSROOMS GET BACK OPEN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. IT PROVIDES
SIX POINT SIX BILLION TO HELP
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS COVER THE
COSTS OF REOPENING SAFELY WHICH
OF SUCH THINGS LIKE TESTING.
AND DIFFERENT PHYSICAL CHANGES
IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE DISTANCE AND SUCH
AND IT ALSO WITHIN THAT SIX
POINT SIX BILLION. ALLOWS THE
DISTRICTS TO SPEND MONEY ON
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION AND
SUPPORTS AN UP THAT TOTAL TWO
BILLION. IS SPECIFICALLY FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION GRANTS FOR
THE TO SUPPORT ANY. SPECIFIC
COSTS RELATED TO THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. AND VARIOUS SAFETY
PROTOCOLS ARE DELINEATED IN THE
BILL BASED ON THE TEARS OF THE
COUNTY AN ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION IN EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES GRANTS
IS PROVIDED FOR ALL DISTRICTS
TO PROVIDE EXPANDED LEARNING
TIME AND ACTED MAKE
INTERVENTIONS THROUGH. BUT NOT
LIMITED TO SUMMER SCHOOL
EXTENDED YEAR EXTENDED
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME ONE ON ONE
TUTORING AND OTHER IN PERSON
SERVICES. THE BILL ALSO PUTS IN
THE STATUTE THE GOVERNOR'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT COMMENCING
MARCH FIRST JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
THAT SCHOOL STAFF AARON CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WILL BE
PRIORITIZED FOR VACCINES IN
TIER ONE B. STATEWIDE. AND THAT
10% OF ALL NEW VACCINE SUPPLY
WE RECEIVE WILL BE OFFERED TO
K. TWELVE EDUCATORS AND KATIE.
EDUCATORS STAFF AND CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BUT IT DOES NOT AND I
WILL BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS MAKE
VACCINATION A PRE REQUISITE FOR
BEGINNING IN PERSONS
INSTRUCTION. THE BILL ALSO
TEMPORARILY WAIVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT HOME SCHOOLED
STUDENTS SUBMIT STANDARDIZED
TEST RESULTS WHICH WERE
DISRUPTED DUE TO THE CORVETTE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ALLOWING THE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO CAL GRANTS
TO HELP PAY FOR COLLEGE THE
BILL ALSO. IF THE DISTRICT OR
SCHOOL HAS ALREADY REOPENED IT
DOES NOT IMPOSE NEW
RESTRICTIONS OR RULES ON THAT
SCHOOL IN ANY SCHOOL THAT
ALREADY HAS ITS FULL RE OPENING
PLAN. AND IS INTENDING TO
REOPEN PRIOR OR RATHER I DON'T
SHE RE OPEN OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN OPENED RATHER RETURNING TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IF THEY
ALREADY HAVE A PLAN FOR THE
WEEK RETURNED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND INTEND TO DO SO
BEFORE THE DATE SPECIFIED IN
THIS BILL. THEN THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL ARE
NOT IMPOSED ON THOSE DISTRICTS.
AB EIGHTY SIX WAS HEARD BY OUR
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON
TUESDAY. SENATE PASSED THE
COMMITTEE WITH A UNANIMOUS VOTE
WITH ALL MEMBERS PRESENT. IN
WITH THAT MEMBERS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER CENTER JONES FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. MISTER PRESIDENT RISE
WITH AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK FOR
AB EIGHTY SIX. FROM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE MEMBERS.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR JONES SET.
ONE GENERAL JONES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BODY
FOR AB EIGHTY SIX I APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
IMPROVE ON THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THIS BILL. BUT THE REALITY
IS THAT IT STILL DOES NOT GO
QUITE FAR ENOUGH THE BILL IN
CHIEF DOES PROVIDE INCENTIVES
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO RE OPEN
BUT IT FAILED TO PROVIDE WHAT
HEALTH EXPERTS RECOMMEND AND WE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS DESPERATELY
NEED A GUARANTEED OPTION TO
RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM
IMMEDIATELY. THIS AMENDMENT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL BY
DOING THE FOLLOWING FIRST IT
WOULD REQUIRE EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA TO
OPERATE STUDENTS AT ALL GRADE
LEVELS THE OPTION OF A FIVE DAY
WORK WEEK INSTRUCTIONAL MODEL.
INTO IT WOULD GIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE FLEXIBILITY
NEEDED TO MEET SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT PRACTICABLE IN
ORDER TO BRING KIDS BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM. NOTHING IN THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD PROHIBIT
DISTRICTS FROM CONTINUING TO
OFFER A DISTANCE LEARNING
OPTION TO FAMILIES BUT IT WOULD
PROVIDE RELIEF TO THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. THAT NEED
TO BE BACK IN SCHOOL. MANY OF
YOU IN THIS ROOM ARE PARENTS
JUST LIKE I AM AND YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW CRITICAL
EDUCATION IS TO A CHILD'S
SOCIAL AND ACADEMIC DEVELOPMENT
AT ALL AGES. THIS PAST YEAR HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH. AND ACADEMIC OUTCOMES
OF STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AS OF TODAY CALIFORNIA RANKS
FORTY NINE OUT OF FIFTY STATES
IN GETTING KIDS BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM ACCORDING TO RECENT
ANALYSIS IS. AB EIGHTY SIX
TAKES A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT WE OWE IT TO THE
FAMILIES AND THE STUDENTS TO DO
MORE. SURELY MY DEMOCRAT
COLLEAGUES DON'T WANT TO IGNORE
THE ADVICE OF CDC AND THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THAT SCHOOLS. ARE THE SAFEST
PLACE FOR CHILDREN. TEACHERS
AND STAFF TO BE. WE CAN DO
BETTER FOR CALIFORNIA WE CAN
MAKE THIS BETTER. BILL WE CAN
MAKE THIS A BILL A BETTER BILL
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS ACCESS TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WITHOUT
FURTHER DELAY. PARIS THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SEARCH FOR COURT
PURPOSES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I MOVED BACK TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
ASTRONOMICAL. MEMBERS
EMOTIONALLY THE MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE THIS IS NON DEBATABLE.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR MAJORITY VOTE
SENATORS HERTZBERG IS LOOKING
FOR A VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BACKER I
FOR JUST NO BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CORTESE I DALLY.
DODD I TO RAZA HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO HI HURTADO
HI JONES NO LAYARD I LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO- CHIRLA
BOTH. PAN HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH
FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE RIGHT I BY CASKEY I
WIENER. HI WILK NO. FIVE TWENTY
NINE NO SIX AMENDMENTS RELATE
TO ON THE TABLE. TURNING BACK
TO. SIR BATES FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
MISTER PRESIDENT I ALSO HAVE
AMENDMENTS OF THE DESK- M.
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ
THOSE AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR BATES SET TO. TURBAY'S
FOR GEORGE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OF THIS SET OF
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY SIX A SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD THEY STRIKE OUT
FEWER THAN FIVE IN ANSWERED NO
LESS THAN THREE INTO AB EIGHTY
SIX AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN AB
EIGHTY SIX WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS TO RETURN.
FOR AS LITTLE AS ONE DAY PER
WEEK OF CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE NO LESS THAN
THREE DAYS OF CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE FUNDING OUR KIDS NEED MORE
AND BY THE WAY THEIR PARENTS
EXPECT MORE. OUR PATH TOWARD
NORMALCY FOR OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR CULTURE REQUIRES US TO DO
MORE WE CAN DO BETTER SO AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS AND A NO VOTE ON THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S MOTION TO
TABLE THEM WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
CENTER CENTER. THANK THANK YOU
IN ORDER TO REPORT PURPOSE I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
IDEA MOVE TO LAY THE NAMES ON
THE TABLE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE A
MOTION TO LAY THE MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE THIS IS NON DEBATABLE
CENTER HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
AYE VOTE. SENATOR BATES HIS
ACTION FOR NO VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BATES. NO BACKER. I
FOR JUST KNOWS BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO AYE CORTESE AYE DALLY.
DODD I TO RAZA I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES. NO LAYARD I LEYVA. HI
WIRE HI MELENDEZ. NO MAN. FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHIRLA
BOTH. NO HAN HI PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
I AM BURKE AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK NO. MARCH
TWENTY NINE KNOWS SEVEN THE
MINUTES ARE LAID ON THE TABLE
RETURNING TO THE BILL IN CHIEF
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE BY MEMBERS SIR BORDERS.
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF
OF MY WIFE AND I. I'M JUST SO
THANKFUL THIS BILLS MOVIN
FORWARD. I GOT TWO LITTLE BOYS
BOTH OF WHOM WERE IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND IT IS BEING A YEAR
ALMOST THAT THEY'VE BEEN OUT OF
SCHOOL I KNOW A LOT OF YOU.
UNDERSTAND THIS HAVING CHILDREN
OF YOUR OWN OR GRANDCHILDREN.
THIS IS A HUGE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. CAN I GET TELL
YOU DESPITE BEING AN EDUCATOR
FOR WELL OVER A DECADE. I
THOUGHT IT WAS A PRETTY GOOD
PROFESSOR. AND THEN I WAS ASKED
TO TEACH MY TWO BOYS MATH AT
THE ELEMENTARY LEVEL I REALIZED
HOW CRUMMY A TEACHER I REALLY
HELPING. I COULD EVEN FIGURE
THAT ACTUALLY HELD THEIRDOING
IT THESE DAYS BUT ANYWAYS THIS
IS JUST A HUGE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I'M EVEN THOUGH
WE HAD- SOME HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS- TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS- PIECE LEGISLATION MORE
PALATABLE THIS IS DEFINITELY
WHAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS AND ON.
COULD BE VERY THANKFUL TO BE
SUPPORTING IT. THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
A PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY SIX AND I REALLY
WANT TO THANK OUR LEADERSHIP
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE GOVERNOR- AND-
OUR SERVER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THAT SERVER BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND OF THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
THIS IS AN AMAZING. TEAM EFFORT
WORKING WITH A BROADER ARRAY OF
SOMETIMES WARRING STAKEHOLDERS-
TO COME UP WITH LEGISLATION-
THAT IS A MAJOR STEP FORWARD
AND THAT'S IT COMMUNICATES ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT THE STATE
IS HERE TO SUPPORT YOU TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH A FUNDING THAT%
YOU NEED TO RE OPEN TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE VACCINES- THAT
WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT OUR
TEACHERS AND OUR EDUCATION
STAFF- CAN BE AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE. AND THAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO WHAT'S NECESSARY
NECESSARY TO PARTNER WITH AND
SUPPORT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS
THEY MOVE TOWARDS RE OPENING SO
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
MADE THIS A REALITY. RIGHT NOW-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME WHO
HAVE SAID WELL WE SHOULD
MANDATE RE OPENING WE KNOW THAT
ALL OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTSARE
DIFFERENT AND MIGHT HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS BUT THERE IS
ONE COMMON NEED THE SCHOOLS
NEED TO REOPEN. AND NOW WE HAVE
DONE THIS WE ARE PASSING THIS
TODAY IT IS NOW UP TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO TAKE THE
STEPS THAT THEY NEED TO DEPLOY
THESE RESOURCES TO DEPLOY THE
VACCINES AND TO GET THE SCHOOLS
REOPEN QUICKLY IS HARD TO
OVERSTATE THE DAMAGE THAT HAS
BEEN DONE AND IS BEING
INFLICTED ON OUR CHILDREN ON.
OUR STATE'S CHILDREN OUR FUTURE.
BY NOT HAVING AN- LEARNING. THE
HARM TO THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
THE PHYSICAL HEALTH AND THE
SOCIAL- DEVELOPMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT OF THESE
KIDS THE NUMBER OF KIDS WHO
HAVE DISAPPEARED ENTIRELY.
SINCE REMOTE LEARNINGS STARTED.
IS JUST STARTLING AND
UNACCEPTABLE. AND WE NEED TO
GET THE SCHOOLS RE OPEN. AND I
KNOW IT'S HARD BUT TODAY WE ARE
PROVIDING POWERFUL TOOLS. FOR
SCHOOLS TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION. I ALSO TO DO WANT TO
COMMENT SPECIFICALLY
COLLEAGUES. ON MY OWN HOME
CITY- SPECIFICALLY THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WAS EDUCATES OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS. IN SAN
FRANCISCO SINCE LAST FALL
NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND PRIVATE
SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE BEEN IN
SCHOOL NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND
SO FOR THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO PAY FOR
PRIVATE EDUCATION SOME OF WHOM
HAVE WALKED HAVE VOTED WITH
THEIR FEET BY LEAVING THE
SCHOOLS AND PUTTING THEIR KIDS
IN PRIVATE SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY
WERE SO DEEPLY FRUSTRATED WITH
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS LACK OF
PROGRESS TOWARDS RE OPENING.
THOSE KIDS GOOD EDUCATION ALL
THIS DOES IS EXACERBATE THE
EXISTING EDUCATIONAL
INEQUITIES. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
PARTICULAR. AND SO I WANT TO
URGE AND SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO ACCEPT THIS
FUNDING THE INITIAL SIGNAL FROM
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS NOT
EVEN TO ACCEPT THE FUNDING. TO
ACCEPT TO RE OPEN TO GET OUR
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL TO GET THE
TEACHERS VACCINATED AND TO MOVE
FORWARD ON IT A NOT. WITH THESE
KIDS LANGUISHING AT HOME IT'S
NOT FAIR AND IT IS DESTRUCTIVE
TO THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF OUR
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY OUR RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE BUT
BEFORE I MOVE FORWARD I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE SOME OF THE
ISSUES FACING OUR PARENTS AT
HOME AND THIS IS SUCH A
PERSONAL ISSUE TO PARENTS AS
STUDENTS ARE SOMEONE'S BABY SO
I RUN INTO FAMILIES WHOARE
CRYING AND PLEADING FOR US TO
OPEN SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEIR
CHILDREN ARE FALLING SO FAR
BEHIND AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FINANCIAL MEANS TO GET THEM
HELP. AND ON THE OTHER HAND I
WANTED TO PARENTS WHO ARE
TELLING ME THEY'RE KEEPING
THEIR STUDENTS AT HOME AND ARE
GETTING THEM TO THERE'S SO
CLEAR THERE IS. SOME
DEFICIENCIES AS A PERTAINS TO
PROVIDING INCOME FAMILIES THAT
SUPPORT TO CONTINUE TO HELP
THEIR STUDENTS AT HOME. SO I
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE PRO TEM
LEADERSHIP. AND MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WORK SO HARD ON THIS BILL.
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE. AND I KNOW FIRST HAND
THAT THEY WORK TIRELESSLY. TO
BE THOUGHTFUL. TO TAKE
EVERYONE'S INPUT INTO
CONSIDERATION. TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE SAFE OUR TEACHERS
ARE SAFE OUR ADMINISTRATION.
FAITH IN OUR ENTIRE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY. I KNOW THAT MANY
WILL SAY THIS IS NOT A GREAT
SOLUTION. BUT IT IS A GOOD STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND AS
OF THE ONLY TEACHER BOB WAS
CURRENTLY ON LEAVE AND I MY
FELLOW TEACHERS WHO PREVIOUSLY
TAUGHT. WE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS FIRSTHAND WE DO BUT IT
IS PROJECTED THAT STUDENTS WILL
FALL BEHIND. NINE MONTHS THAT
IS AN ENTIRE ACADEMIC HERE. AND
I ALSO KNOW THE TEACHER THAT
THEY GAP WILL ONLY GROW
EXPONENTIALLY AND WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO CATCH UP. OUR STUDENTS
SO I ASK ALL OF US TO JUST
CONSIDER. WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
A GIVE SCHOOLS THE ABILITY TO
TAKE WHAT WE OFFER. AN OPEN
SCHOOLS SAFELY. IT DOES GIVE
FLEXIBILITY WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR SOME OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND I WILL
SHARE THERE'S A LOT OF-
SUPERINTEND. OVER TENANTS THAT
I MET WITH RECENTLY SCHOOL
TEACHERS PARENTS. THAT YOU CAN
SEE EVERYONE'S DIVIDED ON THE
ISSUE BUT THIS IS AS GOOD AS
FIFTY IN THIS MOMENT. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PUT THE
FUNDING FOR TIME SURE
EVERYONE'S SAFE. BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT THIS CONVERSATION
SHOULD NOT STOP HERE. WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO MONITOR. AND
ADVOCATE FOR MORE SUPPORT. AND
WITH THAT. I ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU MISTER. ON
MARCH SIXTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THIS GAVE EMERGE POWER TO
GOVERN NEWSOM WITH THE STROKE
OF A PEN HE BLUDGEONED SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
CREATING AN UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
DOUBLE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S WREAK HAVOC ON
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT GENERATION BY
CLOSING OUR SCHOOLS. EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT JUSTICE LEARNING HAS
BEEN AN ABJECT FAILURE AND THAT
LEARNING LOSS IS REAL HOW BAD.
WE WON'T KNOW FOR YEARS. BUT IN
ADDITION TO OUR CHILDREN
SUFFERING INTELLECTUALLY
THEY'VE STRUGGLED EMOTIONALLY
AS WELL. THE NONPROFIT FAIR
HEALTH WHICH COLLECTS DATA FROM
PRIVATELY BUILD INSURANCE
CLAIMS HAS RELEASED THE
FOLLOWING DATA AND IT'S
DEVASTATING NEWS FOR TEENAGERS
THIRTEEN TO EIGHTEEN. CHANGES
IN DATA FROM APRIL NINETEENTH
TO APRIL TWENTY SHOW THE
FOLLOWING DEPRESSION. 84%
ANXIETY BUT 94% SELF HARM THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
PERCENT. AND OVERDOSES A 119%
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT'S
MORE THAN JUST HARD COLD DATA
THAT'S OUR MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCE CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
GENERATION AND OUR CHILDREN
SHOULD GET EVERY POLICYMAKER
PAS. THE TRUTH IS AB EIGHTY SIX
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING TO REOPEN
OUR SCHOOLS. I BELIEVE WITH OR
WITHOUT THIS BILL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I WANNA REOPEN WILL.
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
WANT TO RE OPEN WON'T. SO IF
THIS IS NOT A SCHOOL RE OPENING
BILL WHAT IS IT. I BELIEVE IT'S
A C. Y. A MANEUVER BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TO GET PARENTS TO
BELIEVE HE'S DOING EVERYTHING
HE POSSIBLY CAN FOR THEM. SO
THIS MORNING I WILL BE
RELUCTANTLY VOTING FOR AB
EIGHTY SIX. BECAUSE MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEED THE FUNDING TO
MEET SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND OPEN
SCHOOL SAFELY. I ALSO SALUTE
ALL OF YOU WHO WORKED ON THIS
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS THE BEST
DEAL. THAT YOU COULD GET. BUT
YOU KNOW THE TRUTH IS. THAT WE
DON'T NEED A B. EIGHTY SIX.
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR HAS
ABILITY HIMSELF TO PUT KIDS
FIRST IN SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER RE OPENING OUR SCHOOLS.
AND HE'S CHOSEN NOT TO DO SO
HE'S CHOSEN TO HIDE BEHIND AB
EIGHTY SIX. AND I HAVE SIMPLY
WANTING TO SAY TO THE GOVERNOR
MR NEWSHAM OPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
THANK SENATOR WORKCENTRE
MELINDA'S. I AM PLEASED THAT WE
FINALLY HAVE A PLAN TO REOPEN
OUR SCHOOLS ARE HAS BEEN ROLLED
OUT BT FRANKLY THIS PLAN
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ROLLED OUT.
MONTHS AGO. I MEAN THE DAMAGE
HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE AND I'M-
I GUESS I'M A LITTLE SHOCKED TO
HEAR. SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
TALK ABOUT THE DAMAGE THAT HAS
BEEN DONE TO THE STUDENTS ONE
WE'VE KNOWN THIS DAMAGE IS
BEING DONE FOR MONTHS AND WEEKS
NOW. IN OVER A YEAR. I HAVE A
STUDENT IN MY DISTRICT- AND I
LIKE TO SHARE HIS COMMENTS WITH
YOU IF I MAY. HE SAYS MY NAME
IS CAMERON FOR MACHINERY. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MY APOLOGIES.
MY NAME IS CAMERON SOUTHWICK IN
NINETY AS BE PRESIDENT OF
ELSINORE HIGH SCHOOL WELL TO
MARK THIS PAST SEMESTER WAS
ROUGH FOR MANY STUDENTS AT MY
HIGH SCHOOL AND OTHER SCHOOLS
ELSINORE HIGH SCHOOL 45% OF THE
FRESHMAN CLASS HAD AT LEAST ONE
HALF IN THE FIRST SEMESTER OF
HIGH SCHOOL. IT WAS A HARD
ADJUSTMENT FOR ME GOING FROM
MIDDLE SCHOOL TO HIGH SCHOOL IN
PERSON BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR THE CLASS OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR FURTHERMORE
THIS IS THEIR FIRST IMPRESSION
OF HIGH SCHOOL WHAT ARE THEY TO
EXPECT THE REST OF THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL CAREERS TO BE. AS FOR
UPPERCLASSMEN WE HAVE LOST OVER
TWO HUNDRED CLASSMATES TO
CONTINUATION SCHOOL PRIVATE
SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
SIMPLY MOVING OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS FROM OTHER HIGH
SCHOOLS HAVE MENTIONED THAT
SCHOOLS BECOME DIFFICULT
TIRESOME AND MOTIVATIONAL TO AN
EXTEND FAR BEYOND WHAT YOU MAY
SEE. THE DEPRESSION RATE IS
RISING FASTER THAN KEVIN
NINETEEN SPREADS AND IT IS
EXTREMELY UNHEALTHY FOR
TEENAGERS TO BE TRAPPED IN
THEIR ROOMS FOR LONG PERODS OF
TIME. WE HAVE LOST ZERO
STUDENTS IN OUR DISTRICT TO
KEVIN NINETEEN HOWEVER SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN WE HAVE LOST
THREE STUDENTS TO SUICIDE. TO
HAVE GOOD HEALTH WE NEED TO GET
PHYSICAL MENTAL AND SOCIAL WELL
BEING. SITTING ALL DAY WORKING
ON SCHOOL WORK IN FRONT OF A
COMPUTER WITH NO COMMUNICATION
EXCEPT THREE DEVICE IS NOT
HEALTHY IT IS MISERABLE. I SIT
BACK AND WATCH THE PRIVATE
CHARTER SCHOOLS GO TO SCHOOL IN
PERSON. AND WONDER WHAT'S GOING
ON. WHAT MAKES PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ANY DIFFERENT WE BREATHE THE
SAME AIR SHOP THE SAME STORES
AND WALK ON THE SAME GROUND. SO
MY QUESTION IS WHAT DO I TELL
THE STUDENTS I REPRESENT WHO
DESIRE TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL AS
MUCH AS I DO. AND YOU ALSO.
HAVE TO BE ON SAM INSTEAD OF
SITTING AT A DESK WHAT IS THE
JUSTIFIABLE DELAY. THIS IS JUST
ONE OF MANY EMAILS THAT I
RECEIVED FROM HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND I'M SURE. MANY OF
YOU IN THE ROOM HAVE RECEIVED
EMAILS LIKE THIS AS WELL. SO I
HAVE TO AGREE. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE GOVERNOR
COULD. GO BEYOND THIS BILL IN
REQUIRING THAT THE SCHOOLS OPEN
BECAUSE AS THIS BILL SITS RIGHT
NOW IT DOESN'T. WE NOW REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO OPEN. BUT IF THEY DO
OPEN THEY COULD THEY COULD HAVE
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. ONE DAY
A WEEK. THAT'S THAT'S HARDLY
REALLY MUCH OF AN IMPROVEMENT
THESE KIDS NEED TO BE BACK IN
SCHOOL. I'VE I MEAN I'VE GOT
THREE MY OWN IN HIGH SCHOOL I
KNOW THERE'S AT LEAST PROBABLY
HALF OF THIS BODY WHO HAS KIDS
HOME AS WELL YOU'VE SEEN THE
CHANGE THAT IS GOING ON IN
THESE KIDS THIS. THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT WENT INTO IT. BUT IT
JUST DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH. MY
FEAR IS THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SEE KIDS GOING BACK TO ANY TYPE
OF REAL- VALUABLE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. UNTIL NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S TOO LATE SO I WILL REACH
ME RELUCTANTLY VOTING FOR THIS
BILL TODAY AS I DID IN
COMMITTEE I WANTED TO MAKE MY
COMMENTS KNOWN AND I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU HOW THESE KIDS
ARE FEELING BECAUSE AS ADULTS
IT'S BEEN AWHILE SINCE WE'VE
BEEN IN SCHOOL BUT YOU REALLY
NEED TO HEAR THE PAIN THAT
THESE KIDS ARE GOING THROUGH.
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO BE THEIR
CLASSMATES IN B. AND AN IN
PERSON ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
LOCAL. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
ALL GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IT IS
UNDISPUTED THAT OUR CHILDREN OF
ANY AGE OUR STUDENTS OF ANY AGE
<c.magenta>EARN BETTER IN THE CLASSROOM</c>
IN PERSON WHAT IS DISPUTED IS
HOW WE DO THAT HOW DO WE GET
THEM BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM
SETTING THIS IS MY FIRST
PANDEMIC AS IT PROBABLY IS FOR
ALL OF YOU AND THERE ARE NO
EASY ANSWERS IN A PANDEMIC THIS
IS AN INSIDIOUS DISEASE. AND
THERE ARE NO EASY SOLUTIONS TO
MY COLLEAGUES WHO WANT US TO
MANDATE OPENING SCHOOLS I WOULD
SAY TALK TO SOME OF YOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHEN I'VE TALKED TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGH IN MY
DISTRICT AND OUTSIDE THE
DISTRICT THEY HAVE SURVEYED
THEIR PARENTS BETWEEN FORTY AND
70% I KNOW THIS ISN'T IT A
SCIENTIFIC STUDY IT'S ANECDOTAL
BUT FORTY BETWEEN FORTY AND 70%
OF PARENTS SAY THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO SEND THEIR STUDENTS
BACK BUT THEY DO NOT FEEL SAFE
SENDING THEIR PARENTS. OR
STUDENTS BACK SO WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT OUR PARENTS ARE
GOING TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
DECISIONS WHETHER THE SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN OR NOT THIS BILL AS
YOU HAVE HEARD IS THE RESULT OF
COUNTLESS HOURS OF WORK AND AGO
SHE SHINS OVER THE LAST EIGHT
WEEKS THERE ARE A THOUSAND
THIRTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
EDUCATORS AND MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS AND PARENTS. EIGHT
MAYBE IN A DIFFERENT SITUATION
WITH REGARD TO THE CASE RATES
ACCESS TO VACCINES AND HOW
PARENTS FEEL ABOUT SAID NEITHER
TO STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL AS I
STATED ALL. WHO HAVE UNIQUE
NEEDS. OUR WORK OVER THE WEEKS
IN THE CA. EACH SUCH. AND THE
NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
AND MARGINALIZED STUDENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE. TWO OF MY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT VOTED TO REMAIN IN
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR. BECAUSE
THEY'RE HEARING FROM THEIR
PARENTS THAT THEY WILL NOT SEND
THEIR STUDENTS BACK. AND THE
INFECTION RATE OF FIVE TO
NINETEEN YEAR OLDS IN ONE CITY.
IS EXTREMELY HIGH. THEY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MEET THE
DEADLINE TO RECEIVE A SHARE OF
THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. WELL SOME
SCHOOLS MAY NOT RE OPEN IN THE
CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR. IT IS
STILL CRITICAL TO SUPPORT THE
SCHOOLS WHEN THEY DO REAL OPEN.
AB EIGHTY SIX ALLOWS A
PERCENTAGE OF EXPANDED LEARNING
RECOVERY FUNDS TO USE FOR RE
OPENING PURPOSES. FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT DID NOT RECEIVE
THE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
GRANT. I'M VERY PROUD OF THIS
PROPOSAL THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
THE SCHOOLS RECEIVE TO HELP GET
THEM BACK ON TRACK. IS THIS
BILL PERFECT ABSOLUTELY NOT
NOTHING IS BUT IT IS A START. I
BELIEVE THAT WILL HELP SCHOOLS
AND EDUCATORS TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AS WELL AS MEET THEIR
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS. I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE. FOR THEIR COUNTLESS
HOURS OF WORK. OUR COLLEAGUES
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR A LONG IS
TO GET THIS TO. ALL OF YOU. I
SENATE STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHTY SIX GIVING AB EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR DR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I DON'T HAVE ANY
PREPARED REMARKS THAT TODAY IN
FACT I DIDN'T- PLAN ON GETTING
UP THIS MORNING BUT- YOU LISTEN
TO THE PROMISE OF ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE FLOOR.
THIS MORNING IS PROMPTED ME TO-
YOUR TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IT- THREE WEEKS AGO WHEN THIS
LANGUAGE ON THIS BILL FIRST
CAME OUT. I WAS VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSED I DID OP ED IN MY LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS LET'S GET OUR KIDS
BACK IN SCHOOL. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED I GOT NUMEROUS
CALLS FROM PEOPLE THAT WORK IN
AGREEMENT- WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT. TEACHERS SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS EVEN SOME
SPERINTENDENTS. AS WE PROGRESS
THROUGH THIS DISCUSSIONS
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY. I
THOUGHT IT WASN'T FIFTY FIFTY
BUT IT MIGHT EVEN BE VIA WITH
PARENTS SIXTY FORTY. ON WHAT IN
THEIR KIDS TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
60% OF THEM 40% NOT. LET'S GET
STRAIGHT I'VE GOT TWO
GRANDCHILDREN THE TO GO TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS. IT'S NOT SO
ROSY IN PRIVATE SCHOOLS. ARE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF KIDS IN
PRIVATE SCHOOL SINCE PARENTS
ELECT NOT TO SEND THEM BACK. TO
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S SAFE. SO I REALLY
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE- I THOUGHT THE BILL
IMPRINT ORIGINALLY WAS SO
HORRENDOUS. OF OUR BUDGET SHARE
OUR LEADER- PRO TEM ATKINS AND
THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR
REALLY DOING AN OUTSTANDING JOB
AND LISTENING WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WHILE I'M
ON THE SUBJECT OF THE GOVERNOR.
I REALLY BELIEVE TO LAY THIS AT
THE FEET OF OUR GOVERNOR. AND
BLAMED THE GOVERNOR FOR HOW
THIS IS WORK WITH OUR SCHOOLS
IS REALLY SHORT SIGHTED THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS I THINK
IT WAS- ARE GOOD COLLEAGUE-
FROM- RIVERSIDE. SORRY I CAN'T
REMEMBER ASSEMBLY BLEW THAT-
BUT BUT ANYWAY TO SAID WE'VE
NEVER PARTICIPATED OR BEEN IN A
PANDEMIC BEFORE SO TO ALL THE
SUDDEN HERE IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TRY TO REWRITE
THE PLAYBOOK FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENED FOR THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS JUST DOESN'T REALLY MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE TO ME THIS IS A
GREAT STEP FORWARD. AND YOU
KNOW THE OTHER THING WE'VE
CALIFORNIANS WE AS AMERICANS WE
ARE RESILIENT. OUR PARENTS WILL
WORK WITH OUR KIDS ARE TEACHERS
WILL WORK WITH OUR KIDS AND WE
WILL RECOVER. FROM WHERE WE ARE
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH ALL THE
STUDIES IN THE ASSESSMENT. BUT-
WE WILL BE THERE FOR THE EIGHTY
THE HELP OF OUR KIDS IN THE
FUTURE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
RIDE BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER PRESIDENT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
LEADERSHIP- AND I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE INCREDIBLE HARD
WORK. THAT IT TAKES WITH ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS. I JUST WANT
TO. SURE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
REALITIES OF MANY OF THE
RESIDENTS IN MY DISTRICT AND
ACROSS THE STATE. I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MANY OF THOSE
FAMILIES WHOSE MEMBERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. ESSENTIAL
WORKERS IN THE SENSUAL
INDUSTRIES. REAL HUMAN BEINGS
THEY REALLY REALLY WORK HARD
EVERY DAY TRYING TO RAISE THEIR
FAMILIES TRYING TO RAISE OUR
KIDS TO GET A GOOD EDUCATION.
THEY ARE HOUSEHOLDS WILL NOT
MULTIPLE WAGE EARNERS AND
THEIR- WORKING IN NON PP
PROTECTED INDUSTRIES. THESE ARE
FAMILIES ARE HIDDEN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT BY AS HIGH AS
50% OF DEATHS AND CASES IN
THEIR COUNTIES. THEY LOOK FOR
SAFETY. ON THE OTHER HAND IS OF
THE SAME FAMILIES WHOSE
CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING THE
WORST FROM LEARNING LOS. THESE
ARE THE TWO THINGS THAT HADTO
BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION AND
I BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
ADDRESSES BOTH SAFETY AND
RECOVERY AND RE OPENING. SO
WITH ALL OF THAT OUR RIGHTS TO
SUPPORT A. B. EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOUS SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF- EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX- AS A- FATHERS TO
CHILDREN WHO- ARE- IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE DOING DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT ALSO AS A
PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES IN PEDIATRICS. HAVE
BEEN URGING A RETURN TO SCHOOL-
AS RAISED MANY CONCERNS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT ON THE FLOOR
ABOUT- THE HEALTH. OF CHILDREN
CLEAN THEIR MENTAL HEALTH. AT
THE SAME TIME- THOUGH I ALSO
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SAFETY IN THE SCHOOL. AND I DO
WANT TO. THURS REMIND PEOPLE WE
STARTED OFF THE SESSION WITH A
PRAYER- ABOUT THE OVER HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE WHO DIED OF COLD
INCLUDING OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I DO WANT TO JUST THAT
DISABUSE ANYONE OF THE NOTION
THAT CHILDREN- CANNOT DIE OF
CODED OR BECOME VERY SICK FROM
CODED. SO THAT'S CERTAINLY A
VERY REAL RISK IT'S CERTAINLY
MUCH SMALLER THAN THIS PEOPLE
ARE OLDER AND I SHOULD REMIND
YOU THAT WE HAVE TEACHERS AND
STAFF TO ACTUALLY HIGH RISK WHO
WORK AT SCHOOLS. EVEN THE
CHILDREN THEMSELVES AND THAT'S
WHY YOU HEAR FROM PARENTS
SAYING. YOU KNOW I AM TIMES
CITATIONS ABOUT SENDING MY KIDS
TO SCHOOL EVEN THOUGH I MAY SEE
MY- CHILD NOT DOING SO WELL THE
DISTANCE LEARNING I AM. STILL
NOT THAT EAGER TO SEND MY KIDS
TO SCHOOL BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT THEY'RE SAFE.
AND THAT IS. WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT- NOT ONLY ARE WE
PROVIDING RESOURCES THIS BILL
THAT- I KNOW THAT- BILL THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WORKING TO
TRY TO GET. ACCESS TO GP- FOR
EVEN FREE TV FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACCESS TO LOW COST
TESTING OTHER VERY IMPORTANT
SAFETY MEASURES. BUT I WOULD
ALSO- MAKE NOTE THAT- FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE SO EAGER TO GET KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL AND CERTAINLY
I'M ONE OF THEM- IF THERE'S ANY
CRITICISM MIGHT MAKE OF THE
GOVERNOR IS THAT NOT SURE IT'S
REALLY FAIR ONE. WOULD BE IS
THAT UNFORTUNATE TOO MANY LOCAL
OFFICIALS- WE'RE NOT WILLING TO
ENFORCE VERY IMPORTANT SAFETY
STANDARDS PREVENT SPREAD THE
DISEASE LIKE MASKING LIKE
BUSINESSES ARE APPROPRIATELY
OPEN. WHERE WE CAN HAVE
OUTBREAKS AND SPREAD. AND WE
SAW A HUGE SPIKE IN CASES.
WHERE OUR HOSPITALS OVER RUN.
IN DECEMBER AND JANUARY AND
FORTUNATELY WE'RE NOW IN A
DOWNTURN SO WE HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS SAFELY. SO
YOU KNOW I DO AGREE WITH THAT
MY GOOD FRIEND TO SAN FRANCISCO
WITH THAT- WE NEED TO URGE OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND OUR- YOU
KNOW THE- PLACE TO WORK THERE
AND THE PARENTS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO GET SCHOOLS BE OPEN
AGAIN AND CERTAINLY THIS BILL
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN GIVING
THEM THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO LET'S GO
LET'S WORK WITH OUR LOCALS
LET'S LOOK AT PARENTS WITH WITH
OUR TEACHERS AND STAFF OR
SCHOOL LEADERSHIP TO TRY TO GET
THE SCHOOLS RE OPENED THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO MOVING
FORWARD. BUT ULTIMATELY THIS
CAN ONLY HAPPEN IF WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
ENSURE THAT WE STOP THE SPREAD
OF THIS DISEASE THAT MEANS
PROMOTING VACCINATION
CONTINUING TO WEAR MASKS
URGING. PEOPLE NOT TO MIX
HOUSEHOLDS UNTIL WE GET ENOUGH
PEOPLE VACCINATED AND SO WE
NEED TO DO OUR PART TO ENSURE
OUR. SCHOOLS CAN OPEN SAFELY AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BAKER THANK YOU ARE RISE IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL WHEN TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES TO WORK DAYS AND
NIGHTS MANY WEEKENDS TO MAKE
THIS A POSSIBLE. THIS SCHOOLS
REOPENING PLAN GIVES US HOPE.
THIS PLAN GIVES US A PATHWAY
FOR KIDS TO RESTORE SOME OF
THEIR CHILDHOOD IN SOME OF THE
EMOTIONAL HEALTH AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS YOU OUR TIES
THE VACCINATION OF TEACHERS.
FURTHER STRENGTHENS THAT PASSED.
EARLY ON I CALLED FOR TEACHER
THAT'S NATION DAYS THOSE ARE
HAPPENING NOW TODAY AND
TOMORROW AND I COMMEND ALL
DISTRICTS ALL COUNTIES THAT ARE
MOVING TO VACCINATE TEACHERS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THIS
PACKAGE IS NEEDED BECAUSE WE
CAN'T AFFORD A CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS CAN'T AFFORD. TO LOSE
MORE VALUABLE CLASS TIME OR
SEEN THAT SCHOOL IS MORE THAN
JUST LEARNING BUT ALSO THE
EMOTIONAL AND SOCIAL VALUE OF
INTERACTING WITH PEERS. I KNOW
I SEE THIS EVERY DAY I JUST
HAVE TO LOOK DOWN THE HALLWAY
AND SEE MY TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO ARE DESPERATE TO
RETURN TO SCHOOL. THE GOVERNOR
WAS IN MY DISTRICT ARE
YESTERDAY AND WE TOWARD A
SCHOOL WE SAW HOW THIS IS
WORKING TO SCHOOL IS TWO THIRDS
OF THE KIDS BACK. ONE THIRD NOT
BACK- CHOSEN TO BE AT HOME. AND
THE SCHOOL IS WORKING THEY HAD
THE PP THEY HAVE EQUIPMENT THEY
HAVE THE SAFETY. THAT IS A VERY
POSITIVE STORY IN FACT THAT
DISTRICTS. OF PALO ALTO HIGH
SCHOOLS WILL ALSO BE BACK NEXT
WEEK AND HOPE THAT BECOMES A
MODEL FOR OUR REGION. I BELIEVE
THAT WITH THE PP BUT WE KNOW
OUR OUR GROWING KNOWLEDGE OF
THE VIRUS AND NOW WITH THE SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE. WE CAN GET OUR KIDS
ARE BACK IN THE CLASSROOM. I
WAS NOT CONFIDENT IN THE SAFETY
I WOULD NOT SEND MY OWN KIDS
BACK. LET ALONE ASK OTHERS TO
BACK THIS- THAT IS THE PATHWAY
TO GET OUR KIDS BACK. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR COURT
CASE. THANK YOU MISTER-
VERIZON'S THE TO A BOTH BOTH SB
EIGHTIES. AND I WANT TO THANK
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE THREE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS SOME WORK SO
HARD ON THIS- CENTER LABOR
CENTER- LAYERED- IN- YEAH
SKINNER CENTERS SKINNER OF
COURSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE ASSIST. THEM HI I WANT TO
TRY TO MAKE A POINT QUICKLY- WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT. THIS
ACTION TODAY IS REALLY DIVIDED
INTO TWO. ALMOST SEPARATE
PIECES TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
URGE THE RE OPENING OF OUR
SCHOOLS AND I THINK THIS BILL
DOES STRIKE A GOOD BALANCE
BETWEEN LOCAL CONTROL AND
LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE. AND MANY
OF US HAVE SERVED ON SCHOOL
BOARDS I THINK WE NEED TO
RESPECT THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
WHO SERVE ON THOSE BOARDS
NOTICE PLEASE YESTERDAY TO SEE
A LETTER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION.
URGING PASSAGE OF THE BILL.
DESPITE DESPITE SOME CONCERNS
THOSE ELECTED OFFICIALS HAVE A
HISTORY. OF WORKING OUT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ISSUES.
THOSE DISTRICTS ARE NOT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOME OF THEM ARE
ENTIRELY HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SOME OF THEM ARE UNIFIED
DISTRICTS SOME OF THEM ARE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WILL HAVE TO APPROACH RE
OPENING DIFFERENTLY ALL OF THEM
HAVE HIRED INVENTED AN
APPOINTED SUPERINTENDENTS THAT
THEY HAVE CONFIDENCE HAVE- WE I
THINK WE- NEED TO RESPECT THAT
AND I THINK. THE GOOD WORK OF-
IT'S LEGISLATURE IN THOSE
CHAIRS HAS RESPECTED THAT LOCAL
CONTROL. BUT WHAT IF THERE WAS
NOTHING ELSE. THE CAUSES TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD REALLY
BE THE OTHER PART OF THIS BILL
THE FOUR POINT SIX. BILLION
THAT WILL GO TO. BUT THAT WILL
GO TO XCELERATED OF LEARNING
THROUGH TUTORING COMMITTEE
LEARNING HUBS IN A ONE
EMPHASIZE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT. ONE THING WE'VE
LEARNED IN OUR HISTORY AS A
COUNTRY IS THAT. SEPARATE IS
ALWAYS UNEQUAL. AND I WANT TO
HARKEN BACK TO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
SENATOR DRAWS SO WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM THIS PANDEMIC AND
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC NOT
BECAUSE BY THE LEGISLATURE NOT
BECAUSE BETTER SCHOOL BOARDS
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IS. THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS VERY REAL. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SAID LITTLE BIT EARLIER.
THERE'S A PUBLIC PRIVATE DIVIDE
THAT IS VERY REAL. THERE IS AN
AFFLUENCE AND POVERTY DIVIDE
THAT IS VERY REAL THERE'S A
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DIVIDE THAT
IS VERY REAL. AND WE ALSO
LEARNED FROM THURGOOD MARSHALL
IS THAT THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
DIVIDE. HIS SOCIAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
IMPACT ON THE STUDENTS WHO
SUFFER THOSE CONSEQUENCES. SO I
THINK THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT REASON THAT WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I WOULD
PREDICT THAT IT WILL BE THE
LAST INVESTMENT. WE NEED TO
MAKE A TO INVEST ON THE
RECOVERY OF THE STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN. I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT BY
ACTUALLY BY TWO HAD NOT PLANNED
ON SPEAKING. THIS MORNING BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO LISTEN
TO THE DISCUSSION- AND WHILE
COMMENDING EVERYBODY WORK ON
THIS BILL WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT DURING THIS TIME. A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE I HAVE WORKED
VERY HARD I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FACT. BUT LET US RECOGNIZE
NOTED DURING THIS TIME THE WORK
OF ALL THE ADMINISTRATORS WHO
HAVE TRIED TO MAKE. THE
SITUATIONS WORK. LET'S NOT
FORGET LET'S RECOGNIZE THE
TEACHERS. WHO HAVE WORKED NIGHT
AND DAY HARDER THAN THEY'VE
EVER WORKED IN THEIR
PROFESSIONAL LIVES. NOT JUST TO
TEACH BUT TO STAY CONNECTED TO
THEIR STUDENTS- AND TO BE THERE
FOR THEM. LET US NOT FORGET THE
SCHOOL STAFF. WHO HAS FOUND NEW
AND INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT
SOMETIMES AT THEIR OWN EXPENSE-
AT GREAT PERSONAL RISK TO
PROVIDE MEALS TO STUDENTS WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE RECEIVED
THEM. AT SCHOOL AS PART OF THE
SCHOOL DAY- AND LET'S RECOGNIZE
AND SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
PARENTS. WHO HAVE HAD TO FIND
NEW WAYS TO INTERACT WITH THEIR
KIDS UNVEILED THEIR
PROFESSIONAL- AND WORKING LIVES
WITH THEIR STUDENTS EDUCATIONS.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE
STUDENTS THIS WILL BE THE MOST
DEFINING THAT EPISODE
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR LIVES MUCH
AS WAR HAS BEEN THE DEFINING
EXPERIENCE FOR. S. GENERATIONS
BUT LET'S NOT FORGET THAT- AND
IF WE MAKE THIS VOTE TODAY.
LET'S DO EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO
HELP THEM MOVE FORWARD IN THEIR
LIVES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER ALERT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT- THIS HAS
BEEN A VERY ROBUST DEBATE AND
TO WE HAD A VERY ROBUST DEBATE
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO TIED TOGETHER OF
SOME OF THE THINGS WE HEARD AND
SPEAK TO THEM. BECAUSE WHEN
THIS DEBATE REALLY STARTED WHEN
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED THE RE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS HIS PROPOSAL
WAS REALLY DESIGNED TO. MORE
FORCE SCHOOLS TO OPEN BECAUSE
THE PANDEMIC WAS SO DEEP AT THE
TIME IN THE SUBSEQUENT TIME
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN BETTER-
CASES HAVE DROPPED ACROSS THE
STATE. AND SO THIS BILL
REFLECTS BOTH THOSE FACTS IT
TAKES THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND REALLY DOES PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE TO MOVE PEOPLE TO
OPEN AND REWARDS THOSE THAT
FOCUS. THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION AND THE OTHER HALF
WHICH DEALS FOR WHAT HAS BEEN
CALLED LEARNING LOSS REALLY
DOES GO TO EVERYBODY AND SO IT
REALLY ENABLES PEOPLE TO OPEN
BECAUSE ENABLING IS WHAT HAS
CHANGED IN WHAT HAS GONE ON
WITH THE PANDEMIC. AND WHEN I
TALKED IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
WE HAD HEARD FROM SENATOR
NIELSEN. AND SENATOR NIELSEN IS
LUCKY COMPARED TO THE MOST OF
US BECAUSE HE REPRESENTS
COUNTIES THAT HAVE HAD AMONG
THE LOWEST CASE RATES IN THE
STATE. AND WE ALSO HEARD FROM
SENATOR GARAGE SO WHO
REPRESENTS THE DISTRICT AT THE
OTHER END. WHERE THE CASES ARE
HIGHER IT'S MORE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THERE IS A REAL
CONCERN ABOUT COMING BACK IN
PERSON. THAT I SPOKE TO MY OWN
DISTRICT WHERE THERE ARE MORE
AFFLUENT AREAS LESS DIVERSE ON
THE COAST. AND THEY'RE MORE
DIVERSE AREAS INTERGENERATIONAL
FAMILIES MANY THAT WORK ON
FARMS THAT ARE IN THE IN ONE
PART OF THE DISTRICT AND BOTH
ARE REPRESENTED THERE. AND SO.
WHAT WE HAD TO DO IS CRAFT A
BILL THAT MATCHED ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS. THAT
MATCHED THE DIFFERENCES THAT
EXIST THROUGHOUT OUR STATE OF
FORTY MILLION. AND WE REALLY
TARGETED- THE KIDS THAT HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT DURING THE
DISTANCE LEARNING WE TARGETED
THE KIDS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
THOSE WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
PROBLEMS BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGY
OR CONNECTIVITY ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS THOSE TO JUST
SIMPLY DROPPED OUT FOR WHATEVER
REASON AND THOSE THAT ARE AT
RISK OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT THOSE
ARE PRIORITIZED IN EACH
CATEGORY. BUT IT WAS VERY
SIGNIFICANT THAT SENATOR DORADO
WALKED OVER TO ME AFTER THAT
DEBATE WAS DONE AND SAID YOU
KNOW SOME OF US REPRESENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS EVERY KID IS
DISADVANTAGED AND EVERY KID
NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE TRIED TO ADDRESS
IN THIS BILL AND FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION.
ORIGINALLY THE PROPOSAL WAS
JUST TO GIVE IT UP TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT WERE ABOUT READY
TO OPEN. AND IF YOU DID THAT
YOU ARE PRIORITIZING
DISPROPORTIONATELY. MORE
AFFLUENT DISTRICTS AND YOU WERE
DISADVANTAGING. THE MORE
DISADVANTAGED DISTRICTS IN THIS
BILL WIPES OUT THAT DIFFERENCE
IT BASICALLY SAYS THAT EVERY
DISTRICT WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT MONEY. THERE WAS A
QUESTION THAT CAME UP IN THE
BUDGET DEBATE ABOUT CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND WHETHER THEY WERE
DISADVANTAGED AND THE
DISTINCTION WAS. THAT MANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE DISTANCE
LEARNING ALREADY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THEY WEREN'T STOPPING
THEIR CONTINUING SO THAT
DOESN'T ADDRESS THAT BUT IT
WILL HELP CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN LIKE MANY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND SUSPENDED IN PERSON
ONE. WHEN THE PANDEMIC CAN'T.
NOW THE REAL PROBLEM IS. TRYING
TO TAKE A STATE WIDE BILL AND
NOT HAVING A COOKIE CUTTER
APPROACH AND IT WAS SUGGESTED
EARLIER THAT WE SHOULD MANDATE-
CERTAIN NUMBER OF DAYS BEING
OPEN. WELL THERE'S A CONSISTENT
STANDARD IN THIS BILL ON THE
CONSISTENT STANDARDS
FLEXIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE. IF WE
HAD A CLASSROOM THAT WAS SO BIG.
THAT YOU CAN'T SOCIALLY
DISTANCE AND BRING THE WHOLE
CLASS BACK TOGETHER YOU COULD
HAVE HALF THE WEEK IN PERSON
FOR HALF THE CLASS HALF THE
WEEK IN PERSON FOR THE OTHER
HALF OF THE CLASS. DISTANCE
WARNING WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN
PERSON AND IF WE FORCED THEM TO
OPEN IT WOULD HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE SINCE
THEY ALL CAN'T FIT IN THE CLASS
OF PROBABLY KEEP MATH CLASS
CLOSED UNTIL VAT AS WHY THE
CONSISTENT STANDARD IS
FLEXIBILITY SO AS WAS SAID BY
SENATOR CORTESE WITH UP TO
SCHOOL BOARDS DECIDE WITH WHAT
THE LOCALS DECIDE. HOW IT BEST
FOR. AND SENATOR PAM. I WAS
VERY CONCERNED AS A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL WE DON'T LEGISLATE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE THAT
WAS ALSO SUGGESTED EARLIER
TODAY AND IT REALLY LEAVES IT
TO THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
THIS BILL REFERENCES REQUIRED
OR IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE BUT IT DOESN'T DICTATE
WHAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
IS AND THERE WAS SOME
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT. THE
PEOPLE PREPARING THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS PREPARING THE
GUIDANCE SAID YOU SHOULD DO SIX
FEET DIFFERENCE FOR STUDENTS
BUT IF YOU MAKE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT AND YOU CAN'T SATISFY
IT. YOU COULD GO AS LOW AS FOUR
SO THEY RECOGNIZED THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT WAS THERE. THE
END IT IS ALSO TRUE. THERE WAS
A MISREPRESENTATION IN A COLUMN
IN THE LA TIMES THAT IMPLIED
THAT VACCINATIONS WERE REQUIRED
AS PART OF THIS BILL. THEY ARE
NOT IT IS OUR PRIORITIZATION
AND THE CDC. CHURCH AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. WE SHOULD RETURN
REQUIRE IT THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT CDC
GUIDANCE IN PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYS WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH FACT. THE END
AND SO IT MAKES THE DIFFERENCE
IN THE END. FINALLY THERE ARE
REAL CONCERNS. ABOUT DIFFERENT
GROUPS AND HOW THEY MIGHT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS BILL OR
HOW THE BILL MIGHT AFFECT THEM.
AND THERE WAS A CONCERN IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. FETID
MINISTRATIONS OF MARK TO IN
THIS PROCESS. THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THERE'S NO PENALTY AND THERE
WAS A REALLY PROTECTION FOR
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE ALREADY
OPENED THEY GET TO CONTINUE
THEYRE NOT PENALIZED AND
REQUIRED TO CLOSE. THIS DOES
NOT REINVENT THE WHEEL FOR
TESTING. THIS ALLOWS A LOCAL
TESTING. ABILITY TO JUST BE
SIGNED OFF ON AND CONTINUE AND
BY THE WAY SINCE WE HAD THE
BUDGET DEBATE ON TUESDAY. THERE
WAS APPROVAL OF MEDICAID
REIMBURSEMENT FOR LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS AND TESTING AND THAT
WILL BRING MORE MONEY TO THE
TABLE FOR THIS RE OPENING. IN
THE DISTRICTS AND WITH THE
STUDENTS THAT NEED IT MOST-
THERE ALSO IS NO APPLICATION
PROCESS WE DON'T WANT TO SLOW
DOWN. ARE WE REALLY WANTED THIS
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE AND GET OUT
THE DOOR. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
THE DISTRICT'S REDO THEIR
COVERT PLAN IF THEY HAVE AN
EXISTING ONE THAT WAS APPROVED
IN. AND BARGAINED IT JUST
CONTINUES NO REINVENTING THE
WHEEL. AND I KNOW CENTRO
TROUBLED WAS VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE OFFER THE APPROVAL
PROCESS- THAT WOULD GO ON BY.
OF CERTAIN PLAN AND THERE'S A
TRIGGER THAT HALF OF AFTER FIVE
DAY STAY ON APPROVED IT'S
AUTOMATICALLY PUT SO THERE'S
NOT A BUREAUCRATIC DELAY HERE
AND IT REALLY MOVES AND THEN
THERE WAS A CONCERN REYES TO
MANY OF THE MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR. THAT THE BILL WOULD
PENALIZE INDEPENDENT STUDIES
THAT WAS ADDRESSED THAT WAS
TAKEN OUT. OF AND THE BILL IS
GOOD AND THAT IS WHY WE ALL GOT
LETTERS FROM ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SCHOOL BOARDS
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD
SUPERINTENDENTS SAY THEY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ON THE OTHER
SIDE. TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES OR OUR PARTNERS IN
THIS PROCESS AS WELL. AND
SENATOR MELENDEZ MENTION
TUTORING WELL PARA
PROFESSIONALS ARE IN HERE THAT
IS TO RING THAT ALLOWSSTEP ONE
FOR ONE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS OF
GREAT CONCERN. THE VACCINES%
THAT WAS ADDED SINCE IT WAS
FIRST PROPOSED IN THE WAY I
PREVIOUSLY DESCRIBED THAT
PROVIDE SOME OF THE FEARS ABOUT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND TEACHERS
GOING BACK. WE REQUIRE THAT
THERE BE TESTING IN THE PURPLE
TEAR. WE REQUIRE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE WHICH REQUIRES
THE TESTING AND THAT IS TO GIVE
SOME ASSURANCE TO ANY TEACHER
OR SCHOOL EMPLOYEE THAT MIGHT
HAVE TO RETURN IN THE EARLY
CORPORATION PURPLE. AND ALSO
THIS BILL FROM THE FIRST
INCARNATION BEEPS UP
ENFORCEMENT BEATS UP TACTICAL
SYSTEMS SO THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE NOT LEFT BY
THEMSELVES THE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
THINGS THAT ARE SPELLED OUT IN
THIS. THE BILL FORD HERE TO SO
AS I SAID IN FRONT OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS WAS HARD.
THIS WAS HARD BECAUSE WE HAD TO
DO A SENATOR LEYVA REFER TO.
OVER A THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS STATEWIDE DISTRICTS
OF EVERY ECONOMIC STATUS
DISTRICT OF EVERY LEVEL OF THE
PANDEMIC DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO
TEACH THEIR STUDENTS BECAUSE IT
WAS MENTIONED ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF STUDENTS AND I HAVE
TO SAY. WHEN I FIRST HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SCHOOL RE
OPENING WHITE BEFORE EVEN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED THE RE
OPENING. IT WAS LIKE WHY WOULD
WE RE OPEN FOR SIX WEEKS. AFTER
BEING HIT DISTANCE LEARNING FOR
SEVEN MONTHS AND THE ANSWER
WAS. THAT SOCIALIZATION IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THE STUDENTS BUT
GETTING BACK BEING WITH THEIR
PEERS WOULD BE THE BIGGEST HELP
TO MENTAL HEALTH AND PERSONAL
HELP. AS WHAT THE INSTRUCTIONS
SO I THINK THIS BILL ADDRESSES
ALMOST EVERY ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO US IN THIS PROCESS
IT MOVES US AHEAD. I THINK IT'S
A GOOD BILL GOT UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
MISTER PRESIDENT I REQUEST AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SEEN NO
FURTHER MIKE SO I THINK WE CAN
CONCLUDE ON WHAT WE WILL ALL
AGREE WITH A HEALTHY DEBATE.
CENTER SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR SO
FAR AND I THINK WHAT IS EVIDENT
FROM WHAT WE'VE DISCUSSED IS
THAT DETAILS MATTER. AS MANY
PARENTS WANT THEIR CHILDREN
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM THERE ARE
JUST AS MANY WHO ARE AFRAID AND
AFRAID WITH GOOD REASON. THE
PANDEMIC AS OUR FOR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO THE
GOOD DOCTOR REMINDED US. HAS
KILLED OVER HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE AND LEFT MILLIONS WITH
THE LONG TERM HEALTH PROBLEMS.
ANY DISTRESSED ALL OF US THERE
IS NO ONE WHO IS NOT BEEN
HARMED BY THIS PANDEMIC. AND W
WILL NOT BE ON STRESSED OR
UNHARMED UNTIL WE CURB ITS
SPREAD. AND WE CAN ONLY CURB
ITS SPREAD IF WE FOLLOW THE
APPROPRIATE SAFETY PROTOCOLS
AND THAT IS EVERYWHERE
INCLUDING OUR SCHOOLS AND WE
KNOW THAT OUR- STAFF OR
TEACHERS OR PARENTS OR
CHILDREN. ARE NOT GOING TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE RETURNING TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION UNLESS THEY
FEEL SOME CONFIDENCE THAT IT'S
SAFE. AND WE HAVE DONE OUR BEST
TO PROVIDE THAT- BY. ALLOWING
ACCESS TO VACCINATIONS NOT
REQUIRING THEM BUT ALLOWING
THAT ACCESS BY. REQUIRING
CERTAIN TESTING PROTOCOLS IN
THOSE AREAS WITH THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATES AND BY REQUIRING
THE DISTANCE IN THE OTHER
MEASURES THAT WE KNOW ARE
NEEDED WE ALSO KNOW THAT NOT
ALL CLASSROOMS OR SCHOOLS ARE
DESIGNED THE SAME OR HAVE THE
SAME CAPACITIES IF FOR EXAMPLE
THE CDC ITSELF POINTS OUT THAT
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE INDOORS
THE ABSOLUTELY BEST
CIRCUMSTANCE IS ONE WHERE
WINDOWS ARE OPEN AND A GREAT
VENTILATION SYSTEM. I KNOW EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US CAN GO TO
ONE SCHOOL IN OUR DISTRICT AND
SHOULD POINT OUT OF CLASSROOM
MANY CLASSROOMS FOR WHICH THE
WINDOWS CANNOT OPEN AND THERE
IS NOT A GOOD VENTILATION
SYSTEM. SO IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DETAILS ARE DRESSED
AND THAT WE HAVE SET UP A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
FEEL SAFE WHICH WE HAVE DONE
ARENDT. WE ARE NOT RE OPENING
SCHOOLS EDUCATION HAS BEEN
WHILE INADEQUATE IT HAS
CONTINUED WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
CREATING A PATHWAY FOR MORE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION THERE HAS
BEEN AS BEEN POINTED OU IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION IN VARIOUS
DISTRICTS IN VARIOUS PLACES
ACROSS THE STATE BUT WE KNOW IT
IS NOT BEEN. EQUAL OR
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE AND WE
ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH
THIS BILL- THAT IS REALLY. ALL
I HAVE TO SAY ABOUT IT THE REST
OF YOU HAVE MADE SOME VERY VERY
GOOD POINTS- MANY OF US SPEND
FAR MORE HOURS IN THE EVENINGS
ON WEEKENDS THAN WE EVER
EXPECTED BUT IT WAS NECESSARY
BECAUSE DETAILS MATTER AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU HAVING ALL DISCUSSION
DEBATE. SEIZING ON THIS ITEM
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM TEN A. B.
EIGHTY SIX. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
FIVE BAKER. FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY. DODD I TO
RAZA I EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH HERTZBERG
FIVE HUESO HI HER TADO I JONES.
HI WHERE'D I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE
FIVE MELINDA'S. I MEN I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. I PATROL BOAT I PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE RIGHT HI RICK CASKEY.
HI WIENER AYE WILK HI. A
PICTURE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLY GROVE. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. TELL MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WELCOME MEMON MOTION MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THAT CROSS TO DUST
ON FRIDAY SATURDAY AND SUNDAY
MARCH FIVE SIX AND SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE WILL BE
ADOPTED PUBLISHED IN THOSE
MEASURES RETURNED TO COMMITTEE.
OUR MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS WE HAVE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS ITEM
FOR SOONER HERTZBERG ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM INDEED
MISTER PRESIDENT I AM PREPARED.
MA'AM SECRETARY. I'M SORRY MR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FILE NUMBER FOUR IS THE
CONFIRMATION MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF OSHKOSH BHAGWAT AND
ANGELI DILIP OF A- TO THE
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATORS
GOVERNING BOARD MR BHAGWAT IS A
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT THE NEWS UC
DAVIS AND MISCONDUCT OF A WHO I
HAVE KNOWN FOR DECADES IS
PRESIDENT OF NEW ENERGY OPTIONS
A SOLAR ENERGY COMPANY IN
FOUNTAIN VALLEY THEY'RE BOTH IN
SERVING ON THE BOARD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. AT RULES
COMMITTEE WE HAD A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION WITH RESPECT TO
THEIR APPOINTMENT BECAUSE OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE
BECAUSE OF THE CLIMATE
EMERGENCIES AND THE POWER SHUT
OFFS THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
HEAT WAVES WE EXPECT AND PUSH
THEM PRETTY HARD AND BOTH
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED DID A
GREAT JOB AND WERE APPROVED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH.
ON A VOTE OF FOUR ZERO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE ERICA. OTHER
CONFIRMATION OF THEIR
APPOINTMENTS. THANK YOU ANY FOR
THE- OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. STERN SCENE AND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE
LARGEST. BRADFORD HI CABRERA
HIGH COURT TODAY I DALY. DODD
BY THE RAZA. I EGGMAN. GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO.
HI JONES. LAYARD I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ NO MAN.
FIVE NEWMAN. I NIELSEN. NIELSEN
I A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN. HI NUMBER ALL
RIGHT HI WHAT KIND OF STEVE. HI
WIENER AYE WILK. NOW. THIS CALL
AB MEMBERS. WITH A FIFTH. NO
GORGEOUS. DALLY EGGMAN. GROVE
JONES NO FEDERAL OF BOTH.
NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW. TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS FIVE APPOINTMENTS
ARE CONFIRMED MEMBERS NOW
MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SIX. DOCTRINE
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
MEASURE I SEE THAT YOU ARE
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY RATE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR PAN
RELATIVE TO BLEEDING DISORDERS
AWARENESS MONTH CENTER PAM
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT CENTERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT S. YOUR
THIRTEEN WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
MONTH OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS BLEEDING DISORDERS
AWARENESS MONTH. IN THE FEELING
IS A RARE GENETIC CONDITION
AFFECTS AT LEAST FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND VON
WILLEBRAND DISEASE IMPACTS AT
LEAST THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT PROPER TREATMENT PEOPLE
TEMA PHILLY AND OTHER RELATED
BLEEDING DISORDERS OFTEN FACE
SPONTANEOUS BLEEDING EPISODES
UNDER JOINTS MUSCLES INTERNAL
ORGANS AND EVEN THEIR BRAIN.
THIS CAN LEAD TO FREQUENT
HOSPITAL VISITS CHRONIC PAIN
FROM A DISABILITY AND IN SOME
CASES CAN EVEN BE FATAL HOWEVER
WITH PROPER CARE AND ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICAL ATTENTION
PEOPLE THIS RARE CONDITION
CAN'T CONTROL THE BLEEDING THIS
EPISODE'S ENABLE LEAD
PRODUCTIVE LIVES. THIS
AWARENESS MONTH WILL LEAD TO A
GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF
KNOWLEDGE IN THE FIELD BUT ALL
INHERITABLE BLEEDING DISORDERS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO THE PROPER
CARE AND TREATMENT OF ALL
CHILDREN ADULTS ARE BATTLING
THIS CONDITION ON A DAILY BASIS.
EXPECT THE ASPIRIN I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER JUST. OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM SIX.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BECKER AYE FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE. AYE CORTESE
AYE DALLY. DODD I TO RAZA HI
EGGMAN GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG FIVE HUESO I
HER TADO HI JONES. I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA. LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I COULD SHOW BOTH. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE I'M HI CASKEY HI
WIENER. I WILK HI. FIVE PRICE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
NOW MOVING TO OF ITEM TN
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTERS AROUSAL.
THANK YOU SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FIVE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THIS SSSION IN
ROOM THREE ONE NINE ONE. THANK
YOU. SUB COMMITTEE FIVE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE FIVE WILL MEET
UPON THE GERMAN IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS CENTER I CAN
SUGGEST IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE WORK THIS WEEK%
OBVIOUSLY JANUARY FEBRUARY AND
EVEN MARCH- TEND TO BE NOT AS
BUSY MONTHS FOR US IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE GEAR UP TO
HEAR OUR BILLS BUT I HAVE TO
SAY. IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY BUSY
JANUARY FEBRUARY INTO MARCH AND
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK THIS
BODY FOR YOUR DILIGENCE YOUR
WORK AND YOUR DEDICATION HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND AND- WE WILL HAVE
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION ON
MONDAY MARCH EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT
TWO PM.